[Music]  you're incredible do you understand  I'm serious you think I've done it  without you standing next in the big  strong doing this because I'm feeling we  know just keep your head now  [Music]  so I told you about my brother yet  something happened I don't know exactly  what she's gonna rest it's being held at  Rikers Island oh my god that's awful  hey you just got to get him outta there  before something bad happens if you get  killed in there  another 10 grant you get another 10  grand your bubble get out the truth  [Music]  I think something very important is  happening it's deeply connected to my  purpose every day I think about on  twisting and untangling these strings  I'm in and to lead a Pure Life  look ahead in a clear sky ain't gonna  get there  but it's a nice dream  it's a nice dream  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]